glauben sie an ein schicksal oder sind
sie der ansicht sie bestimmen wo es
langgeht
um diese fragen kreist der neue roman
meines heutigen gastes peter stamm ist
so etwas wie der existenzialist unter
den schweizer schriftstellern mit
einfachen worten und starken bildern
lotet er die philosophischen abgründe
des alltags aus und über genau diese
abgründe wollen wir heute reden herzlich
kommen er stand da glaubten sie dann an
ein schicksal
nein nein eigentlich nicht nein warum
nicht
vielleicht weil ich nicht daran glauben
will oder oder weil weil ich mir
einbilde dass ich mein leben in der hand
habe oder dass ich mein leben bestimmen
kann
ich möchte nicht an den sieg glauben ein
sie möchten ich glaube nicht naja ist ja
auch die frage woher kommt das schicksal
wer bestimmt das schicksal gibt's da ich
nicht an einen gott glauben findet ihr
schon mal weg und und warum sollte
irgendetwas im universum vor bestimmt
sein
aber haben sie machen nicht den eindruck
dass nicht sie bestimmen wo's lang geht
im leben sondern das leben selbst
weniger als leben ich glaube auch dass
man einfach durch seine voraussetzung
doch seine genetik der seine seine
kindheit sagen wir auch halt in gewissen
daten gefangen ist und und egal wie man
sich dann entscheidet halt auch immer
wieder am selben ort landen das glaube
ich schon der griechische philosoph
heraklit hat mal gesagt
der charakter des menschen ist sein
schicksal
sehen sie das ähnlich das könnte man
natürlich sagen weil ich meine wir
können nicht bestimmen welche gene wir
kriegen und gut man kann letztlich auch
sagen es ist auch keinerlei weil ich bin
einfach der der ich bin und werde ich
ein anderer wäre ich halt ein anderer
also ich kann ja nicht als der der ich
bin ein anderer sein
daher ist es einerseits schicksal aber
andererseits bin ich halt einfach der
der ich bin
anschließend schon erstaunlich wie viele
zufälle im leben gibt oder
entscheidungen die man getroffen hat die
man auch anders hätte treffen können und
dann wäre man heute vielleicht auch
ein anderer ist das ein gedanke den sie
eben das war die frage wir haben ein
anderer mann wäre in einer anderen
situation man hat einen anderen partner
mit anderen beruf man wird in einem
anderen ort leben aber wenn ich dann
eine andere ich weiß es nicht aber es
stört sie dass das man eigentlich viele
leben hätte leben können wenn man sich
an alles entschieden
es geht ja immer man kann ja immer nach
vorne oder nach hinten schauen wenn man
nach vorne schaut dann gibt es diese
vielen leben wenn man nach hinten schaut
hat man doch auf das gefühl das hat
einfach so kommen müssen dass das hat
irgendwie bestimmt natürlich meine ganze
existenz passiert aber einem einem einer
fahrrad panne die mein vater hatte und
deshalb hat er nie seine ferien
umgestellt und hat er meine mutter
kennengelernt und und so in jedem leben
natürlich tausende von solchen
kleinigkeiten die dann entscheiden
werden aber im wenn man zurückblickt
denkt man dann immer es halt so kommen
müssen und das ist wirklich erstaunlich
ist ein rückblick hat das leben eine
bestimmte folgerichtig keine bestimmte
logik warum ist das so ja noch mal ich
bin der der ich bin und werde diese
fahrrad kann nicht passiert dann gäbe es
mich gar nicht also könnte ich dann auch
nicht zurückschauen und sagen sie dazu
kommen müssen also ich bin halb die
addition alisa zufälle und und gegen die
sicher getroffen haben und von daher
gibt es die nicht gegeben
diese abfolge dann selbst sicherlich
nicht setzen sie jetzt nicht lernen
diese dieser blick in die vergangenheit
in die eigene die erinnerung das
gedächtnis spielt für sie als
schriftsteller eine ganz zentrale rolle
sie schreiben viel dass aus dem
gedächtnis heraus
insofern könnte man sagen sie leben oft
in der vergangenheit was macht das mit
ihnen nicht unbedingt in der
vergangenheit weil ich versuche ja schon
so eine art gegenwärtigkeit in den
texten zu haben
aber es ist eine eine fiktive welt das
schon aber das tun jedoch im grunde
genommen alle weil ich sage das immer
bei lesungen wenn da 400 leute sitzen
ein zahl dann sind es 400 verschiedene
welten die da präsent sind
es gibt ja nicht die eine welt die
objektiv ist und ja in der ich dann 17
uhr schon unser blickwinkel schauen die
richtigen sie schauen die lehre
das sind zwei völlig verschiedene alten
eigentlich aber in gewissen anderen
berufen plant man mannschaft mehr nach
vorne und ich stelle mir das so vor wenn
sie schreiben geht man zurück und
versucht sich an situationen zu erinnern
diese diese erlebnisse verdichtet
nochmal niederzuschreiben
wobei auch in der erinnerung erinnerung
ist zwar vergangenes aber es ist ja
nicht gefühlt vergangen
also meine erinnerungen sind ja im
grunde genommen
einfach die welt in der ich lebe und und
da denke ich jetzt nicht jedes mal dazu
das war vor zwei jahren das war vor fünf
jahren das war 24 jahren sondern es ist
im grunde genommen die welt in der ich
lebe und und dann kommt dazu dass sich
das ja auch gestalte also das ist zwar
das material ist zwar vergangenes aber
ich bin ja dann auch in der gegenwart
und gestaltet da sind und mache etwas
daraus das ist dann sehr innen in der
präsenz der schriftsteller jean-paul hat
mal geschrieben dass die erinnerung das
einzige paradies ist als thema nicht
vertrieben er hat das reich auch schon
gehört das zitat ist schön was werden
sie daran schön
naja weil genau das was er natürlich
sagen das ist etwas was uns niemand
wegnehmen kann es genauso wie die
gedanken die frei sind und die uns
niemand stellen kann man kann man kann
uns einsperren man kann uns foltern man
kann mit uns machen was man will aber
man kann uns nicht unsere erinnerungen
nehmen man kann uns nicht unsere
gedanken nehmen
aber man kann auch nicht zurück und
etwas ändern zum beispiel das kann
schmerzhaft sein die zeit nicht umkehre
ja natürlich zu können
das kriegen wir ja immer wieder mit mit
diesen ganzen geschichten von ich war
gerade jetzt hatte ich im radio wieder
gehört von einem diese diskussion um die
verdingkinder wo dann ein alter mann
einfach sagt das ist jeden tag bei mir
diese kinder die ich gehabt habe das
geht nicht weg das ist eine beschädigung
die die auch mit 70 noch da ist ihre
kinder hat beschreiben sie selbst aus
paradies ähnlich in ihren vorlesungen
vorlesungen weil die kindheit im
rückblick zu zeitlos erschienene
erscheint und sie schreiben ein
wunderschönes stelle
wo sie über die wurzeln ihres schreibens
sprechen und sie sagen die wurzeln
meines schreibens denke ich waren die
endlosen stunden der langeweile in
meiner kindheit in denen ich mich mit
sinnlosen tätigkeiten und tagträumen und
der hielt und ein beispiel dass sie
nennen sind solche auf schweizerdeutsch
schon mal sagen sie haben so stoff den
sie dann auseinander nehmen oder ein
seil das sie in einzelteile wieder
dagegen und stunden haben die sie
eigentlich machen oder müssen sie nicht
machen
aber was ist es daran was gibt also es
gibt auch in einem buch von ihnen ein
ein protagonist der dann in einer
schaffenskrise sich wieder energie holt
kreative energie durch solche
tätigkeiten was fasziniert sie daran es
ist er hat fast etwas meditatives
natürlich es geht im grunde genommen
warum einfach eben da zu sein und nicht
nicht immer in gedanken zu sagen nicht
immer in ich denke es ist wie die
buddhistischen mönche die dann den
vorplatz vision oder so und versuchen
einfach nur zu wischen und nicht anders
zu denken was sein wenn man das zu
denken was gewesen ist es gibt so eine
art von meditativer ruhe
was sind die momente wo sich heute diese
meditative ruhe haben oder diese dieses
treten im moment dessen fall schon beim
schreiben
also es ist schon ein moment wo auch die
zeit dann muss ich die zeit nicht mehr
wahrnehmen also wo ich dann plötzlich
merken sind wir schon vergangen und und
ich habe eigentlich war das nicht
bewusst dass ich muss eigentlich diesen
zustand kommen wo ich wo ich so
außerhalb der zeit bin damit ich
schreiben kann
aber das ist nicht immer einfach
herzustellen als wenn zu viel anderes
los ist dann geht das nicht als partner
gewisse technik herum dass diese
situation ja ja ja ja also man lernt das
natürlich irgendwann sowie an jemand der
meditiert auch seine techniken hat wie
er in diese in diesen zustand bekommt
das geht mit musik das geht mit auch
lesen das schon geschriebenen dass man
wieder in den tag hinein
aber sie machen das am schreibtisch sie
gehen da nicht draußen im garten und
machen gartenarbeit oben in diese zu
sein das ist noch nicht da bin ich da
wieder zu sehr abgelenkt aber ich gehe
oft auch spazieren das ist ganz gut dass
bei mir immer funktioniert einfach gehen
spazieren nicht im sinne von flanieren
und sich umschauen sondern wirklich
immer dieselben wege im wald einfach
geradeaus gehen und und dann praktisch
auch gar nicht mehr hinschauen was da
ist und denken mit dem rhythmus der
schritte zu tun ich glaube es nicht so
was das denken anregt
wenn sie auf ihr früheres ich zurück
gucken auf ihre kindheit denken sie da
manchmal auch wer zum teufel war das da
oder ja ich will ja es ist seltsam ich
bin einerseits hat man ich habe immer
gesagt ab 12 oder so denkt man nicht
base ungefähr der mensch der ich heute
noch bin also auch da ich habe jetzt
nicht das gefühl ich bin ein völlig
anderer mensch
und dann schaut man sich fotos anfang
der zeit und merkt plötzlich das ist ja
schon ein anderer gewesen und aber aber
im grunde fühle ich schon so eine
einheit der person also ich bin mir ich
bin mir nicht fremd als kind es sind
eher die fotos die dann falsch sind
obwohl sie natürlich richtig sind aber
in meinen erinnerungen bin ich glaube
ich die habe ich angepasst an an denen
der ich heute bin also her dass sie
haben sie diese pläne angepasst jaja man
sagen wir nur ganz banales beispiel 70er
jahre da haben wir alle ganz
schreckliche kleider angehabt achtzigern
noch schlimmere damals waren die nicht
schrecklich für uns und darum sind sie
in erinnerung dass keine schrecklichen
kleider aber wenn ich die fotos
anschauen dann sind sie natürlich
schrecklich und dann wenn ich meinen
gott was haben wir daran gehabt strikt
krawatten
sie sind durchaus auch zeitlos gekleidet
dachte ich hier aber in den siebzigern
nicht mal in der wandelhalle bund und
was verbindet sie wenn sie jetzt sagen
so ab 12 zieht sich da etwas durch was
ist das ist schwer zu sagen wer hat
schon meine ich denke so wie ich heute
noch wirklich relativ ruhiger mensch ich
bin jemand der viel nachdenkt ich bin
lieber in kleinen gruppen 19 großen
ich habe eine abneigung gegen lärm ganz
viele dinge eigentlich und und plötzlich
schon auch dieses fantasieren dieses
schreiben ich meine zwölf war es noch
nicht konkrete schreiben aber es war
schon auch diese sich in andere welten
begeben an diesen anderen welten zu
spielen in anführungszeichen dieses
tagträumen r schreiben sie genau das hat
ja wenn ich leuten das schreiben erklärt
sage ich immer dass wir das nächste
glaube ich ihn in ein leben von jemandem
der nicht schreibt ist dieses ein
tagträumen wo man einerseits fantasiert
aber andererseits die phantasie ihn auch
lenkt also nicht wie im traum wo man dem
ausgeliefert ist sondern man kann im
takt haben ja auch so ein bisschen
bestimmen wo es lang geht muss lang geht
obwohl sie beim schreiben sagen sie ja
sie bestimmen da nicht was lang geht
sondern sie gucken sich an zu was die
figuren machen und es ist nicht ein
machen sondern einfinden muss man ja
vielleicht ist wo es langgeht schon zu
viel gesagt aber man entscheidet sich
sagen wir es so wenn ich eine wanderung
mache ich weiß nicht vielleicht wohin
ich gehe aber ich entscheide mich an der
kreuzung gilt nach links oder nach
rechts
aufgrund von irgendwelchen erfahrungen
oder ein bisschen voraus sieht man ja
schon also ich sehe halt bis zur
nächsten wegkreuzung und denke das sieht
ja nie nach einem holzweg aus ich gehe
besser rechts so wenn man auf ihr leben
zurück guckt sieht man also fährt er
hofft dass es überhaupt nicht gradlinig
verlaufen ist als sie haben unglaublich
vielfältige dinge gemacht eine
kaufmännische lehre dann haben sie als
buchhalter gearbeitet
dann haben sie also auf dem flughafen
gepäckstück eingepackt und hat gesagt
sie haben als journalist gearbeitet für
diverse schweiz familie nach für den
nebelspalter satirische texte
geschrieben kandidierten mehrfach für
die grünen immer noch und diese zeit vor
dem großen durchbruch vor agnes vor 20
jahren das war auch so nicht stehen hier
vor nicht immer eine leichte
zeit sie haben danach viele absagen
gekriegt von von verlagen für diesen
stoff wie wir sind sie umgegangen mit
dem mit dem scheitern damals aus der der
weg ist nicht geradlinig aber ich habe
schon ab mindestens 20 gewusst dass ich
schreiben will und dann war es halt
damals gab es keine schreiber ausbildung
und zwar halt einfach so die frage wie
komme ich zum schreiben und und da habe
ich jobs gemacht einfach um geld zu
verdienen das gerade am flugplatz da bin
ich sehr sehr gern gewesen das fand ich
einen ganz tollen job
also von daher gibt schon so eine
einrichtung von anfang an aber innerhalb
dieser oder mit diesem ziel habe ich
dann halt verschiedene dinge gemacht war
der flughafen job auch sowas ja und was
man denken muss nein ich glaube da kann
auch so ein bisschen dieses so dass das
harte was männer da habe ich mögen wie
holz hacken oder so also diese
körperliche arbeit in jedem wetter
draußen zu sein ich hab nicht mal geld
ist da ich find s toll die flugzeuge
enteisen im schneesturm darum die
flugzeuge abzuspritzen das fand ich
schon toll aber das war irgendwie so
eine reine männersache glaube ich andere
gehen dann halt ich weiß auch nicht
fußball spielen oder so naja aber jetzt
habe ich die frage von scheitern
das schreiben scheint dann umgegangen
naja ich glaube also ich glaube was
wichtig war dass ich nie gedacht habe
ich bin das chemie und die anderen
merken es nicht sondern ich habe immer
wenn das zurück kam mir halt gesagt das
war halt nicht gut genug
das war es auch nicht also wenn ich die
texte heute anschaut die waren nicht gut
ich glaube damit muss man jeder der
etwas erreichen will muss das können
dass er auch einfach sagt ich muss auch
einschätzen können wie gut ich bin und
ich muss mich auch verbessern können
weil wenn man sich von vornherein ein
bilder man sei der tollste und im
rektorat habe ich erlebt bei jungen
autoren dann jeden koffer verteidigt und
sagt das ist irgendwie das muss so sein
dann kommt man nie weiter ich glaube da
ist es wichtig dass man einfach sagt
okay ich bin noch nicht gut genug ich
muss weiter nach und das war danach der
erste text agnes der ihnen nicht mehr
peinlich waren schreiten sie das nicht
klappt hat das mal gesagt am text ist
dann gut wenn er nicht peinlich ist das
heißt natürlich viel mehr als es geht
nicht darum was drinsteht ob daher milch
extrem drin sind sondern es geht darum
dass der text dann wie unabhängig von
mir ist dass ich sagen kann der text
kann für sich alleine stehen
der ist nicht mehr persönlich mit mir
verbunden und darum ist er mir auch
nicht mehr eigentlich egal was da drin
steht
ok ich dachte irgendwann muss hinter dem
stehen können was man geschrieben ja man
steht schon dahin dabei aber er ist wie
von mir losgelöst
das sage ich auch beim schreiben dass je
länger ich arbeite einem text desto
weiter weg geht und es gibt einen punkt
wo man nichts mehr dran ändern kann ob
er gelungen ist oder nicht aber ich mag
dann einfacher ist jetzt fertig hat sich
wie abgeschlossen und dann steht ja
eigentlich für sich und dann kann ich
dich mit dem zu lesung und liest aus dem
vor aber im grunde genommen denke ich
nicht immer anders was dahinter stehen
es ist nicht als hätte ich lieber nicht
was geschrieben sondern der ist wirklich
das steht für sich
wir haben über das scheitern jetzt kurz
gesprochen viele ihre figuren scheitern
auch an an der nähe an dieser
unmittelbarkeit wie sie vielleicht
suchen aber sie sagen dass das so zu
sagen das gegenteil von glück das ist
eben gerade wichtig für geschichten sie
sagen glück macht keine guten geschichte
das zeug ist der floh er hat genau das
lässt sich nicht erzählen oder sowas ist
ja es ist kinderleicht schlecht erzählen
ja warum denn eigentlich warum lässt
sich das glück dass ich glaube das steht
sogar ein abriss schon drin wo sie sagt
glück sind punkte und striche
es ist ja oft so dass glück sind so
momente und momente sind sehr schwer zu
beschreiben da müsste man vielleicht ein
gedicht schreiben oder so da gibt es
dieses dieses gedicht von goethe das ist
überall mit bistro man das ist ein
moment
das ist glück aber ein roman
das sind drei zahlen bei goethe wenn er
das über 300 seiten geschrieben hätte
wäre das der langweiligsten roman der
weltgeschichte unglück sind auf die
ungleichbehandlung ich meine da
geschehen dinge
man weiß auch auf der roman unglücklich
ist wenn man beim blick auf nicht weiß
dann kann ich sagen ich bin glücklich
weil in den seltensten fällen ich glaube
dass rechte glück ist nicht das glück
das lotto könig sondern
ist das glück das man einfach eines
morgens wenn man aufsteht und die sonne
scheint und alles stimmt das ist für
mich glück aber glücklich im moment haft
könnte man sich denken ja als ich habe
diese stelle indes anders gelesen dass
das glück als punkten besteht wie ein
populistisches gemälde von sera und erst
wenn man als der distanz guckt sieht man
ja dass inhaltlich glücks die glücks
punkte
aber so besteht sozusagen aber das sind
momente wie auch in einer beziehung da
liegt diese momente wo alles perfekt war
und dann gibt es auch die die grauen
tage wo dann wo man dann so vor sich hin
lebt und seine sachen macht und die dann
jetzt vielleicht in erinnerung dann auch
verschwinden weil weil da dann eben das
glück jetzt einfach ich bin nicht mal
sagen umgeht geworden ist aber einfach
nicht nicht so prägnant da ist und und
unglück ist eben bewegung und und das
sind auf dinge die geschehen das sind
handlungen das sind schicksalsschläge
und das ist einfach viel zu erzählen
spannende und dazu kommt das natürlich
das scheitern auch viel interessanter
ist als das siegen siegen ist doch
relativ einfach es ist auch nicht so
einfach aber aber scheitern ist viel
spannender wenn man scheitert muss man
sich bewegen da muss man was machen
ich weiß ja auch entschuldigen das ist
ja auch dass ich will jetzt gar nicht
mehr angreifen aber das ist das ein
bisschen langweilig dass er immer
gewinnt die im grunde genommen sind
leute wie simon ammann glaube ich das
skispringen als die sind viel spannender
weil da geht rauf und runter und bei
roger federer ging es auch mal ein
bisschen runter aber im grunde genommen
ist ja immer auf der höhe und das macht
sein leben jetzt für für eine erzählung
ein bisschen weniger interessanten
klagen bei ihnen gab es ja einen
wichtigen moment in der biografie
nämlich paris sie schreiben auch paris
habe sie erwachsen gemacht
in dieser großen stadt kann man sich
verlieren
einsamkeit spielt eine wichtige rolle
und wahrscheinlich ist einsamkeit etwas
das beim schreiben jetzt als
schriftsteller stelle ich mir vor oft da
ist was für ein verhältnis haben sie zu
einsamkeit japan schreiben ist ja nicht
nicht da jemanden das ist ja könnte fast
sagen schreiben ist ja ein mittel gegen
einsamkeit in dem man sich eben seine
figuren schafft oder eben dann auch das
tagträumen dann ist man mit menschen
zusammen ist er allenfalls wenn man dann
aufhört zu schreiben dann ist man allein
ich habe inzwischen bin ich sehr gern
allein also ich habe aber damals war das
schon ein problem in der stadt ist das
alleinsein ist ja oft gar nicht das
problem das problem ist ja eher dass die
anderen nicht allein sind als dass man
immer die anderen sieht und denkt diesen
alle zusammen lassen überall paare wenn
man alleine essen geht und so wenn ich
in der natur allein bin dann habe ich
nie das gefühl einsam zu sein weil da
jemand anders ist also einsam bin ich
eigentlich erst wenn ich diese die die
eben nicht einsam sind aber beim
schreiben ist es schon eine art
voraussetzung dass man dass man sich
eben zurückziehen kann für mich jetzt
aber diese figur an diese fiktiven
personen in der normandie geben ihnen
geborgenheit oder ist ein bisschen krank
oder ja ja schon ja also nähe
geborgenheit ist ein bisschen hoch
gegriffen aber es ist schon das ist
gesellschaft wann ich bin ja mit den
zusammen die führen dialoge die tun
dinge ja aber die reden ja nicht mit
ihnen
nein aber ich muss auch nicht immer
selber reden nicht wir auch gern zu also
ist das person wo sie sich besser
verstanden fühlen als von maria und es
therapeutisch jetzt 40
eigentlich müssen mich nicht verstehen
aber ich meine es ist gesellschaft sagen
wir es so
das tut eben das darum träumt man ja
auch tag also man um einfach um sich zu
unterhalten auch es ist auch
unterhaltung unterscheiden ich finde es
interessant wie viele figuren ich habe
schon gesagt in ihren büchern suche nach
nähe scheitern dann
aber und wenn ich mich recht erinnere
war auch ein so ein entfremdung erlebnis
der anstoß für agnes oder einer der
anstöße sie saß mit ihrem damaligen
freundin am ufer der saar in fribourg
und beschreiben das so als ich meine
freundin betrachtete war als mir
plötzlich als erkenne ich sie nicht
dabei kam sie mir so fremd vor
trotzdem hatte ich den eindruck sie zum
ersten mal wirklich zu sehen und nicht
nur das bild das ich mir von ihr gemacht
hatte und diese bilder die wir von uns
selbst machen von anderen das ist ein
ganz wichtiges thema da ihm erstellt
denn die liebe denn den blick auf den
anderen gar nicht nur die liebe ich
glaube man man macht sich sowieso immer
sofort bilder von menschen muss man auch
ich denke das ist evolutionär gibt es
auch gute gründe dafür ich muss sofort
entscheiden wenn ich im wald sie auf
jemanden treffe kann ich den fressen
oder ob kann der mich fressen oder oder
kann ich mit dem ein kind machen und und
darum ist es durchaus sinnvoll dass wir
sehr schnell entscheiden wie stehe ich
zu diesem menschen aber das problem ist
natürlich dass diese bilder kann da sind
und sich schwer verändern lassen wieder
dass man wenn man mal eine meinung hat
von einem menschen dass man die schwer
wieder verändern kann
wie schützen sie nicht dagegen vor dass
er macht das kann man glaube ich nicht
ich kann man muss es ist ein aktiv dass
man immer wieder sich halt sagt oder
versucht sich in menschen hineinzufühlen
und und versucht auch menschen die man
vielleicht nicht mag oder die man die
einen nicht interessieren da trotzdem zu
sehen was was in den menschen sonst noch
drin steckt aber ich glaube das ist eine
aktive tätigkeit die immer wieder neu
gemacht werden muss weil diese bilder
die wir uns machen die gehen nicht weg
das ist glaube ich steckt in uns können
wir eine andere person jemals wirklich
kennen
ich glaube wir können nicht mal um uns
selbst wirklich kennen das ist
vielleicht auch gar nicht der anspruch
aber aber dass man mindestens ein
bisschen mehr versucht auf menschen
einzugehen und und die ihm gerecht zu
werden wenigstens ich glaube da sind
nicht mal das war in nacht ist der
tagung will ihn dann eher man sagt es
gibt mich gar nicht also
wir können menschen gar nicht ganz
erfassen weil sie selbst gar nicht
fertige gestalten sind es ist ja nicht
so wie ein stuhl da kann ich dir gar
nicht auseinandernehmen vierbeiner eine
sitzfläche annelene aber menschen sind
ja auch dauernd in bewegung die
verändern sich dauernd und und es gibt
man kann die nicht festmachen aber ganz
am anfang haben sie gesagt doch da ist
was das sich durch zählt natürlich er
sah man sich glatt
charaktereigenschaften schauen aber aber
es ist auch ganz vieles was nicht durch
zieht und das dauernd in veränderung ist
und was auch jetzt so was wie ein
gespräch heute das lässt sich nicht
planen nicht mal nicht hätten sie eine
andere frage gestellt hätte ich was
anderes gesagt wir werden anderen ganz
anderen haupt
wer weiß also ich kannte das ist ein
dauerndes sich verändernden dauerndes
sich bewegen und und man kann es nicht
festmachen
wie wichtig ist es denn zu fragen wie
mich jemand wahrnimmt um mich selbst
besser kennen zu lernen also kenne ich
mich selbst vielleicht gar nicht so gut
sondern muss ich eher die anderen fragen
vielleicht sogar fremde fragen ja ja ja
wir spiegeln uns schon in menschen oder
ich meine es gibt doch diese bei
tagebuch eines clowns von von volvo der
klar und dann stundenlang vor dem
spiegel sitzt und sich selbst anschaut
weil er einfach lernen muss sich so ganz
sehen wie andere hinsehen aber meistens
die meisten von uns also ich mache das
nicht ich sehe mich relativ selten und
dann ist schon mal ein bild von mir ist
vor allem der spiegel wenig kriege von
den menschen mit denen ich zu tun habe
jetzt diese sehnsucht nach nach nach
spielt eine wichtige rolle und da gibt
es eine stelle im neuen buch wo eine
person versucht mit mit körperlicher
intimität diesen herzustellen das finde
ich ganz spannend dann habe ich gefragt
ob das funktioniert dass er es ist der
protagonist erzählt dabei schien es
nicht nur um den sechs zu gehen es war
aus empfinden wir beide eine art hunger
der nicht zu stillen war das bedürfnis
uns ganz nahe zu sein
ineinander aufzugehen warum ist es
dieses bedürfnis nach nähe nach
verschmelzung vielleicht auch nicht so
stark gegen uns menschen sondern das
interessante fragen oder es gibt ja es
gibt ja tiere zb die die die meiste zeit
ihres lebens allein verbringen und dann
nur zusammenkommen um halt nachkommen zu
kriegen ist schwer zu sagen
mich hat immer fasziniert es gibt jetzt
meine physik ist nicht mehr so ganz
frisch aber aber dass es ja dieses diese
anziehung gibt der der atome dass es
aber wenn die ganz nah kommen dann
wieder eine kraft gibt die sie wieder
auseinander drückt also das dass sie
eben nicht miteinander verschmelzen und
ich fand das immer ein schönes bild das
man eigentlich man will natürlich mit
anderen menschen zusammen sein fast alle
wollen das aber wir haben auch angst
erfordern eben ganz zu verschwinden und
es ist ein
ich glaube seine dauerndes näher kommt
wieder wieder weg gehen und darum können
diese momente dann auch nicht so lange
dauern ich glaube das wäre auch
beängstigend wenn man jetzt ganz wieder
einen menschen verschmelzen würde
es gibt manchmal so paare wo man denkt
die sind wie in einer symbiose und die
die sind immer ein bisschen gruselig
also man denkt man kennen die nicht mehr
alleine mit seien auch also ich finde
das war auch mein anspruch an mich
selbst dass ich irgendwie auch selbst
als mensch ganz bin und nicht nur mit
einem anderen zusammen aber da gibt es
vermutlich unterschiedliche bedürfnisse
jeder hat ein anderes bedürfnis nach
ganzheit oder verschmelzung
diese nähe ist deswegen nach entscheiden
weil sie sagen aus schriftsteller sollte
man den figuren den den dingen über die
man schreiben nicht zu nahe kommt es
braucht immer eine man muss klar sehen
es braucht ein schreiben sie einen
kalten blick in einen text und was sie
damit meinen was hören wir uns ganz kurz
an es liest christian heller wie 0 nicht
das gegenteil von einst ist ist kälte
nicht das gegenteil von wärme kälte ist
nichts kommt nirgendwo her wärme hat wie
licht eine quelle
kälte ist wie dunkelheit einfach da und
als möglichkeit immer vorhanden
wenn nichts mehr ist ist es immer noch
dunkel und kalt auch die kälte im auge
des betrachters ist nicht das gegenteil
von wärme ist nicht böse
die wärme gut ist sie entspringt dem
versuch nicht mitzuschwingen dem versuch
klar zu sehen
dabei ist die absolute klarheit so wenig
zu erreichen wie der absolute nullpunkt
etwas mit kaltem blick zu sehen heißt
nicht es ohne gefühl zu sehen
es heißt nur noch ein blick zu sein und
so in der welt nicht mehr ist das ziel
näher bedeutet wärme da ist man den
menschen die man liebt sich in einen
menschen einfühlen heißt in ihm zu sein
und außer sich das ist nicht
ungefährlich
man weiß nie genau wann und wohin man
zurückkehrt wir haben nur noch einen
blick zusammengefasst bist du angst
gemacht
nur noch ein blick zu sein und so in der
welt wie gelingt ihnen das
wir versuchen sie das herz ja es ist
schon ein einen an sich einfühlen glaube
ich wirklich in diese andere figur
hineinzuschlüpfen und und mit ihren
augen zu sehen und aber es gibt auch
durchaus technische aspekte dass man
auch zum beispiel wirklich sich immer
wieder fragt ist das wahrnehmung oder
ist das urteil also ich schreibe dann
vielleicht nicht in einem text sie weint
ist aber ich schreib tränen liefen ihr
über die wangen
und dann ist praktisch eben ich sehe sie
nur von außen die figur des habe ich mir
widersprochen weil ich sage einerseits
in die figur schlüpft aber andererseits
auch von außen sehen es kommt nicht
darauf an es gibt immer die
erzählfiguren die perspektive als der
ich schreibe und da schlüpfe ich in
figur hinein
aber diese figur sieht die welt eben nur
von außen die anderen figuren und die
kann eben nicht sagen
sie war traurig sondern sie kann sagen
tränen liefen ihr beliefern und dann
muss praktisch der leser selbst
entscheiden warum diese tränen da sind
sie traurig oder bis sie geblendet oder
was auch immer ich finde das ist eines
der starken merkmale ihrer bücher dass
sie eben wenig erklären psychologisch
sondern einfach beschreiben und sie
überlassen sozusagen die
erklärungsarbeit der leserin dem leser
ich habe mich dann gefragt ist es auch
ja warum machen ich glaube schon dass
die texte noch lebendiger werden wenn
man wenn man als leser mitarbeitet das
ist ja auch nur schon die differenz von
film und literatur das empfehlen wird
uns halt alles gezeigt als alles da ich
kann sehen was die für kleider tragen im
buch wird ganz vieles ja nie nie nicht
gesagt und da muss ich mir dann meine
eigenen bilder machen und wenn ich das
im text mit sehr viel sinnlicher
wahrnehmung noch verstärke dann ist sind
wirklich alle bilder finden und den
lesern und das macht sie lebendiger
glaube
das heißt die leserin schreibt das buch
eigentlich zu ende
es ist wirklich eine zusammenarbeit und
das machen wir ja auch ich hab gerade
jetzt ist bald walter burkhardt
ausstellung im fotomuseum und dann habe
ich einen text über ihn gelesen und habe
plötzlich nach der ist ja völlig anders
als ich mir vorgestellt habe aber ich
habe immer dieses bild von balthasar
burkhard gehabt ich habe seine fotos
bekannt ich habe sogar zu hause ein paar
drucke von ihm und wir machen uns
automatisch ein bild von diesem menschen
die weniger wir von ihm wissen desto
lebendiger ist dieses bild
und dann plötzlich kriegt man halt das
wahre bild gezeigt und merkt das ist ein
ganz anderer mensch und so würde ich
vermutlich wenn ich jetzt 20 akten
nehmen würde von 20 leser des buches
während das völlig verschiedene frauen
naja ich finde dass das ist gegen die
acht und das lässt auch die die abgründe
offen also alle im normalen leben ist es
ja auch so wir kennen ja die motive
nicht wissen nicht genau warum
unter regisseuren zu warten warum selbst
vielleicht ja auch nicht ja und sie
haben auch gesagt aber am anfang bei bei
federer
das interessiert sie nicht als person
oder es ist einfach es fehlen diese
abgründe diese brüche die sie
unstimmigkeiten also er hat die bestimmt
auch als mensch natürlich weil es gibt
ja keine und komplexeren menschen aber
die sehen wir halt nicht was ich auch
sehr respektiere dass er das ja da auch
sagt es gibt zwar ein öffentliches bild
das bediene ich da bin ich dann hätte
seine spieler und und alles was an
abgründen da ist das ist seine
privatsache
die muss ja nicht mit uns teilen das
macht ja sehr gut finde ich ihre
inszenierung ist ein bisschen eine
andere
sie sieht man selten lachen auf fotos
sie haben nach sozusagen sie verkörpern
diesen karten blick mit den stahlblauen
augen
das sieht man schon eine fotos wo sie
noch jünger sind
man sieht das aber auch jetzt auf
neueren fotos und manchmal die zigarette
da darf auch nicht fehlen
warum diese inszenierung es ist schon
seit schutz frage ich auch ich will
nicht ich will nicht privat in der
öffentlichkeit sein also ich schütze
mein privatleben sehr und und wenn ich
fotografiert wäre dann
nämlich automatisch sein fotografie
bilder an glaube ich dass obwohl das ist
schon so auch ich meine ich mache schon
aus so ein gesicht in dem alltag ich
aber aber ich will jetzt nicht mein
privatleben darstellen
es ist eine eindringliche ein bisschen
grimmig
so sind sie wenn sie daran das gesicht
passt zu ihm
ich glaube ich habe einfach so eine hohe
stellung meines gesichtes ist nicht eine
lächelnde ich glaube das hat wirklich
zum teil mit muskeln haben wir mal eine
eine kieferorthopädin gesagt es gibt
einfach so muskeltonus hat das zu tun
was wir für einen ein grund gesicht
haben ob das er lächelnd ist oder eher
cremig jetzt in anführungszeichen dass
er ganz mit mit laune zu tun also ich
glaube ich bin eigentlich ein fröhlicher
mensch
ja sie haben auch eine affinität zu
humor zurück in der ersten haben hier
lange führten neben sport eine
satirische zeitschrift geschrieben und
ich habe einen schönen satz gelesen und
sie schreiben wir lachen und weinen über
dieselben dinge
der unterschied besteht vor allem in der
distanz die entscheidung komisch zu
schreiben ist nicht eine entscheidung
für das lachen sondern gegen die nähe
die manchmal eben schwer zu ertragen ist
dass ich nicht wieder beim thema der 11
ja und ich glaube auch dass ich glaube
das wird manchmal verwechselt leute
denken humor oder oder humorvoll
schreiben heißt wie zu schreiben und das
hat mit dem überhaupt nichts und ich
glaube ich würde sogar überhaupt meine
bücher sind humorvoll
da kommen keine lustigen sachen drin vor
aber es geht eher um eine eine
einstellung eine gewisse selbstironie
oder oder ein relativieren von dingen
und für mich ist er so eine
einheitlichkeit oder ein an sich so
wahnsinnig ernst nehmen ist ist etwas
humorlos
es geht gar nicht so sehr um die inhalte
ich hätte ich hätte er gesagt die ironie
ist das was fehlt
das muss aber nicht schlecht sein ich
finde das gut also dann ironie fehlt das
würde ich auch okay weil die ironie ist
wirklich distanz jetzt glaube ich schon
aber ich glaube es gibt so eine eine
grund humorvolle einstellung die ich
hoffe den büchern steckt das heißt auch
dinge
nicht so ernst nehmen neben sich selbst
vor allem nicht so ernst nehmen ist eine
gewisse leichtigkeit zu haben eine eine
durchsichtigkeit eine form von licht zu
haben den texten das lesen nicht alle
leute so es gibt leute die sagen alle
texte seien dunkel aber ich sehe die
nicht als dunkel an
jetzt glaub ich das größte
missverständnis verständlich man jemand
dass sowas steht versteht das so aber
für mich sie meine texte nie düster oder
dunkel oder traurig aber es hat etwas
traumhaftes was dieses leichte liegt
viel an diesem syrien zum teil oder man
weiß nicht genau wie es das traum ist
realität und gleichgültigkeit ist ja das
was nun im titel die sanfte
gleichgültigkeit der welt ist der titel
des neuen romans das spielt an auf eine
schlüsselszene aus dem roman der fremde
von ahlbeck ami französische
existenzialist 42 geschrieben was
fasziniert sie an diesem camille und
warum dieser tippte ich hab den früh
gelesen ganz jung nagel ich und da habe
ich damals tief beeindruckt ich glaube
es war schon als als ungläubiger mensch
muss man ja irgendwie mit dieser welt
umgehen muss er sich gründe suchen wenn
man sich nicht umbringen will
um weiterzuleben und da hat mir kam mir
glaube ich schon geholfen mit mit seinen
existenzialismus also auch mit dieser
einerseits die sinnlosigkeit des lebens
akzeptieren und aber trotzdem nicht
aufzugeben
das ist bei ihnen das ist ja das bild
das er auch verwendet der der eigentlich
weiß dass er hier oben ankommen wird und
trotzdem immer weiter
den stein versucht in die höhe zu wollen
das ist für mich so einem gewissen
szenen religionsersatz das sehe ich
nicht das ist doch total frustrierend
sinnlosen mehr zu leben
nein die ganze zeit tragen zu einer
farce denn ich würde vielleicht ist
sinnlose welt schon zu viel gesagt aber
in einer welt wo man vielleicht
aufgegeben hat den sinn zu sehen also
ich suchte ihn nicht mehr
ich habe mir gesagt die fragen die die
religion stellt sie natürlich oder
die fragen die wir mit der religion zu
beantworten versuchen sind ja dieselben
die alle haben nur wir haben die
antworten der religion ii genügt und
dann suche ich halt andere antworten und
oder ich akzeptiere einfach dass es
keine antworten gibt da denke ich kommen
wir so kamen wir vielleicht und warum
der titel was hat das mit der
gleichgültigkeit der welt so das ist
eben der moment wo wir so der held der
einen menschen umgebracht hat ohne
großen grund und dann ins gefängnis
kommt und das ist der moment wo er
akzeptiert dass er hingerichtet wird
er will vorher noch irgendwie einen
genesungs stellen und dann gibt es noch
dieses gespräch mit dem fahrer wo er zum
ersten mal wo man das gefühl hat er hat
zum ersten mal wird der emotionaler ist
da und irgendwann ergibt er sich ins
schicksal und sagt nicht in schicksal
ergibt er sich in seine schuld auch in
gewissem sinn weil er ist ja schuldig
und und akzeptiert dass er sterben wird
das wäre natürlich im grunde genommen in
jedem leben nicht mal wir haben jetzt
nicht alle an mensch umgebracht aber
jeder von uns muss man akzeptieren dass
er sterben wird und von daher ist es
diese diese haltung hier da gefallen
hatte und auf die ich an spielt dieses
einfach sich sich dem leben ergeben in
gewissem sinn ohne passiv zu werden
müssen wir vielleicht noch kurz erklären
warum es im neuen buch geht
ich kann es jetzt nicht zusammenfassen
aber was ganz entscheidender sicht ist
eine begegnung des erzählers mit seinen
16 jahre jüngeren doppelgänger oder ich
ekel haupt sie sich selbst zu sehen wie
er damals war das verstört ihnen erfolgt
diese person trifft dann auch die
freundinnen dieses doppelgängers die
genauso ist wie seine damalige freundin
und zwischen diesen beiden personen
zwischen dem erzähler christus und
dieser jungen doppelgängerin seiner
damaligen freundin der lena gibt es
mehrere dialoge und wir hören uns eine
kurze passage als ein
dialog davon haben es spricht irina
schönen und christian ehler und sie
haben die ganze zeit in dem gefühl
gelebt jemand folgen ihrer spur
am anfang weiß zum verrücktwerden ich
war wütend auf ihn vielleicht auch
eifersüchtig aber dann fing er an mir
leid zu tun weil er keine wahl hatte
weil sie ein ganzes leben vorbestimmt
war vorgelebt von mir
ich fühlte mich verantwortlich für ihn
wenn alles was man macht zweimal
geschieht wenn jede entscheidung die man
fällt nicht nur einen selbst betrifft
sondern auch einen anderen deinem
ausgeliefert ist dann überlegt man
besser zweimal was man tut
das ist eine seltsame vorstellung dass
es irgendwo jemanden geben könnte wie
mich nicht nur jemanden der aussieht wie
ich der dasselbe leben führt sondern der
auch so denkt und empfindet wie ich ich
glaube ich finde die vorstellung schön
es ist als hätte man eine sehr sehr gute
freunde die alles von einem weiß und von
der man alles weiß ohne dass man darüber
sprechen muss nein es ist als sei man
kein ganzer mensch mehr als löse man
sich auf es ist schrecklich
vielleicht hat ja jeder irgendwo einen
doppelgänger und sie hat man einfach das
pech ihrem zu begegnen
ich weiß nicht weshalb aber ich habe
manchmal das gefühl er existiere nur
meinetwegen wäre ich ihm nicht begegnet
hätte es ihn nie gegeben
als sei er ein kind meiner erinnerung
eine erinnerung die wirklichkeit
geworden ist waren sie nie in versuchung
in unser leben einzugreifen um fehler zu
korrigieren die sie gemacht haben
unserem leben eine andere wendung zu
geben oder einfach aus neugier um
auszuprobieren was dann geschieht
ich habe angst davor wer weiß was dabei
herauskommt für diesen erzähler
christoph ist das eine verstörende
vielleicht sogar kränkende erfahrung die
er macht als er sieht da ist jemand
erlebt einfach sein leben nochmal nach
[Musik]
warum ist das so verstören oder so
kranken aus mehrfachen gründen aus
mehreren gründen
ich glaube eines ist natürlich einfach
dieses der glaube an die eigene 1
wertigkeit die da verloren geht dass es
gibt andere die genauso sind wie wir das
ist erstmal kränkend es könnte auch
beruhigend sei natürlich das andere ist
das ja auch wenn man das gefühl hat sein
leben verschwindet in dem der andere ist
lebt der sowie ein wollknäuel dass der
andere aufrollt dass er ausgerollt hat
und das dann ja dann ist am schluss
nichts mehr da also gibt es auch
hinweise darauf dass taktische dinge aus
seinem leben verschwinden oder dir zu
machen geglaubt hat er korrigiert dann
seine erinnerung zum teil und sicherung
habe ich mich vielleicht getäuscht weil
das ganz anders vielleicht stimmt das
gar nicht was ich mir da zusammengereimt
habe ja es ist beängstigend
es ist natürlich auch ich meine es gibt
keine echten doppelgänger daran glaube
ich nicht aber wir stecken natürlich im
grunde in jedem kopf von jedem menschen
der uns kennt steckt ein doppelgänger
von uns und und der ist auch nicht ganz
wir selbst und und menschen manipulieren
auch diese doppelgänger als ich mache
mir bilder von menschen und und eben nur
schon in dem ich einen menschen mag oder
nicht mag ist diese figur in meinem kopf
eine andere als die figur des menschen
in der realität
das heißt der doppelgänger ist eine
metapher für diese bilder reviers man
von anderen aber auch von uns selbst
natürlich das war nicht so geplant aber
ich mag schon immer wieder was ich immer
wieder dieselben themen habe also dass
da ja genau das thema wieder da ist dass
ich immer hat ja ich meine gibt ist ja
spannend die lena die sieht das ein
bisschen anders also sie sagte ich mag
die vorstellung also es ist natürlich in
der anderen position sie mag die
vorstellung dass die zukunft
festgeschrieben ist das wäre mein leben
eine geschichte so schreibt sie sagt ich
glaube das ist es was ich an büchern
immer gemacht habe dass sie
unabänderlich sind
nicht viel lena steckt liegen wenig
glauben also da das obwohl was was sie
gesagt da will ich dann ja da bin ich ja
meinung das ist das tolle an büchern das
wie kleine welten die die nicht mehr
verändert werden die sich nicht
verändern
das ist das tolle an büchern dass ich da
zu hause tausende von kleinen welten
bestehen habe und ich weiß ich muss sie
auch gar nicht mehr lesen
ich werde auch nicht mehr lesen aber
aber nur schon zu wissen da ist diese
kleine welt die die einfach da steht das
ist schön aber in meinem eigenen leben
möchte ich das nicht
nämlich nicht dass das da alles
vorbestimmt wäre aber man kann sich ja
aus gedanken spielt vorstellen das
eigene leben ist eine geschichte einer
humanen kunstwerk ich habe mich gefragt
was dieses gedankenspiel nicht dem
eigenen leben macht kann das helfen
unserem leben eine form geben
das glaube ich ganz stark ich habe mal
eine hochzeit neben einer
psychotherapeutin gesessen und die hat
mir gesagt dass die tatsache dass ein
mensch glücklich ist mit seinem leben
oder befriedigt ist von seinem leben
ganz stark damit zu tun hätte ob der
mensch eine folgerichtigkeit sieht in
dem leben also es ging ja nicht so sehr
darum was ihm geschehen sondern macht
das sinn und sind könnte man da auch
durch frauen ersetzt also hat dieses
leben eine frau oder war es einfach so
ein gefühl von ich bin dem leben
ausgesetzt ist geschehen dinge die nicht
die mir zu stoßen ohne dass ich keine
kontrolle darüber hat also von daher
glaube ich schon dass dieses dem leben
dem eigenen leben eine form geben
wesentlich zum lebensglück beiträgt
jetzt haben sie das wort sinn erwähnt
und und wenn ich jetzt an camille denke
diese schlussszene da wird dieser noch
so oft gefragt ob er sich ein anderes
leben gewünscht hätte und da sagt er ja
eines wo er aufs eigene leben
zurückblicken kann das ist eigentlich
genau das was der lehrer hier auch macht
und genau um diese geschichte erzählen
zu können
da von sich selbst ja ja ich glaube
schon
es ist auch interessant ich habe mal
über england gelesen dass da viele leute
die den krieg erlebt haben gesagt haben
dass auch die glücklichste zeit ihres
lebens und das ist natürlich weil diese
zeit eine zeit der einer sehr starken
geschichte gar in unserem leben wir
haben dauernd wird es nicht sollen wir
dürfen wir fleisch essen dafür kein
fleisch essen kaufen wir das richtige
toilettenpapier oder all diese diese
diese unsicherheiten und dem krieg war
es ganz klar da sind die bösen wir sind
die guten wir müssen kämpfen das waren
schwierige zeiten wir haben nicht genug
zu essen bomben fallen aber es ist
irgendwie eine eine geschichte ist es
eine klare erkennbare geschichte und es
ist intensiv sind intensive erlesen
augen sagen
und vielleicht hat man in solchen
momenten auch das gefühl man man steuert
das eigene leben man man gibt ihm eine
wendung man hat es in der eigenen hand
und darum sind auch glaube ich
naturkatastrophen so beliebt weil es
auch so dass ein schöner erzählungen
noch dazu weil es da keinen bösen geht
da braucht man kein hitler dazu eine art
babys ein erdbeben da kann niemand was
dafür oder ein erdrutsch oder so anders
sind tolle geschichten weil weil da kann
kann man zusammenstehen und das zusammen
bewältigen man kann menschen helfen die
in not sind
all das sind tolle geschichten für die
für die historischen philosophen
die hatten ein ideal sie hat mir gesagt
eigentlich müssten wir uns müssen wir
lernen uns mit unserem schicksal
anzufreunden oder mit unserer geschichte
könnte man auch sagen armor fathi und
und der friedrich nietzsche in
deutschland wieder so oft er hat das
aufgegriffen
diese vorstellung und hat ein gedanken
experiment gewagt der ewigen wiederkehr
des gleichen und er hat gesagt stell
stell dir vor dein leben wiederholt sich
unendlich fach in jedem einzelnen detail
das heißt wir beides sind schon
unendlich fach hier gesessen und haben
miteinander gesprochen und werden das
nach unendlich fach tun und jede
entscheidung krieg dann natürlich ein
großes gewicht
ist das ein gedanke der der sich der
eher beklemmend ist oder der etwas
befreien das hat eher beklemmend würde
ich sagen ich mag kann ich er dieses
dieser idee von den parallel universen
nicht dass ich daran glaube aber diese
idee dass praktisch bei jeder
entscheidung zwei welten entstehen einer
entscheide ich mich so in einer
entscheide ich mich anders da gab es
diesen wunderbaren diese wunderbaren
filme smoking und smoking ist glaube ich
wo das sind wie ein baum aufgebaut also
bleibt scheidemann man raucht die
zigarette raucht sie nicht und dann
teilt sich das auf und es entstehen
immer mehr mögliche welten und das finde
ich eine sehr schöne vorstellung dass es
irgendwo eine andere welt gibt wo ich
eben damals nicht die kaufmännische
lehre gemacht habe sondern vielleicht
direkt ins gymnasium gegangen bin also
vielleicht gibt es diese stellt sie
nicht dass wir noch ein leben zur
verfügung haben nein das wäre es wäre ja
auch irgendwie jetzt wirklich da muss
man auch ein bisschen bescheiden sein
glaube ich und wenn man bis zu einem
gewissen punkt das gefühl hat man hat
das leben auch geformt oder mindestens
ein paar entscheidungen gefällt dann
muss man auch damit leben können glauben
ich bin jetzt nicht jemand der dann
immer zurückgeht und eigentlich doch
damals was anderes gemacht
ja es hat ja auch was schönes ich mal
auch beim schreiben
ich habe ja jede möglichkeit beim
schreiben das ist ja viel einfacher als
filmemacher nicht kann einfach das
schreiben und oder ich kann das
schreiben das kostet mich gleich viel
aber das schöne ist ja auch diese
entscheidung zu fällen und nicht einfach
zu sagen alles ist möglich sondern all
zu sagen ich werde diesen weg sonst
würdet ihr entscheidung an wert
verlieren danach nochmal zweiten
durchgang gelangt ist als die ganze
kunst beruht ja darauf dass gerne form
dem geben diesen ganzen möglichkeiten
existieren
ein weiteres motiv das jetzt schon
angeklungen ist ist diese diese
dialektik zwischen fiktion und realität
zwischen erzählungen und leben und die
spielt in ihrem ersten roman in arnies
eine ganz ganz wichtige rolle und da
wird die erzählung die fiktion so
mächtig dass sie
die realität einwirkt und wir schauen
uns dazu ganz kurz ein ausschnitt aus
dem trailer zu alice an das buch ist ja
auch verfilmt worden klar
es fiel mir gleich auf als er sich im
lesezeit vom ich setzte die gesichter
schmal und gleich unsere blicke trafen
sich für einen moment wieso hast du
aufgehört mit dem schreiben
ich schreib doch er weiß was ich meine
schätze ich hatte einfach nicht genügend
zu erzielen du könntest der über mich
schreiben porträt als sie den lesesaal
verließ folgte ich bist du bist mir
folgt könnte das ein
[Musik]
saßen nebeneinander auf dem sofa ich
könnte dir ich hatte lange bei diesen
augenblick nachgedacht das ist doch gut
angst wenn du fertig bist da wir müssen
wir reden bisher nicht wirklich glück
macht einfach keine geschichte
wagnis
hast du etwa absichtlich für die
geschichte sag mal hast du sie noch alle
[Musik]
eigenes kriegt ein kind von dir egal ob
die sind eine geschichte bad soden sagen
dass jetzt warte
[Musik]
ich habe nicht gewusst wie wirkliches ja
gab es über ihn nach momente wo die
fiktion mal überhand genommen hat und
auf einfluss aus gibt darf ihr leben
damit sie jetzt lange nachdenken ich
hoffe es nicht aber wir haben noch ein
bisschen aber die wollen sie nicht aber
ich verbringe dass ich jetzt schweigen
hier ich meine sie leben so oft in einer
eigenen geschichte ja ja die haben sich
herr irgendeinen einfluss auf ihr leben
ja aber es ist eben was ich von gesagt
hat mit diesem eine form geben und
dieses der text hat nichts mit mir zu
tun ist wenn ich mir peinlich das heißt
auch dass man das im grunde abschließt
und und dann weg stellt und dann ist es
auch nicht mehr da ist die frage kommen
auch oft weil bei schülern zb ob ich
meine alten wieder normal lesen ist noch
nie gemacht und die meisten autoren die
ich kenne würden das nie machen die
lesen nie ein als buch von sich selbst
also im grunde genommen schließt man die
mir auch ab indem man sie aufschreibt
und dass sie nicht die fiktion glaube
ich die mich allenfalls beeinflussten
werden dass perfektion in meinem kopf
dass ich mir eben bilder macht von
dingen dass ich von gewissen menschen
eine vorstellung haben diese vorstellung
mein verhalten beeinflusst dass das
geschieht bestimmt dauernd wenn wir noch
ein bisschen über ihr schreiben
entsprechen
zum schluss dann fand ich es interessant
zu lesen dass sie am anfang immer eine
frage haben also bei dem buch sieben
jahre ist es zum beispiel die frage
welche macht hat jemand über mich der
mich liebt auch wenn ich ihn nicht liebe
bei agnes ist wie viel macht hat die
fiktion über die realität und im neuen
buch vielleicht was wenn ich eines tages
sieht man begegnen der mein leben
nochmals lebt und dann ist ihr
schreibprozess schreiben sie
die suche nach einer antwort auf diese
frage und sie lassen sich leiten sie
haben die figuren und wissen selbst
nicht wohin die gehen und warum die so
handeln wie sie haben ja weil das das
ist nämlich kunst also das sind ja die
künstlerische das ist ja auch dass das
wertvolle ein kind zwischen prozessen
dass sie eben nicht jetzt einfach ein
intellektueller prozesse sind
das anders natürlich auch was tolles ich
mag auch ein schönes cd rheinbach
folgerichtig logisch konstruiert ist
aber aber ich denke die künstler haben
eben einen anderen erkenntnis weg und
der läuft viel über unbewusstes viel
über über das formen auch also die form
verändert dann auch den inhalt das sind
ganz andere prozesse glaube ich darum
kann auch nicht jeder der schreiben kann
auch mit vorschreiben dass das hat
eigentlich literatur schreiben hat mit
schreiben gar nicht so viel zu tun und
was zeichnet ihn gut der literatur ebene
sind diese prozesse
warum kann ich auch mit mit malern oder
mit musikern sprechen und wir merken das
ist genau die selbe arbeit die wir
machen nur der eine macht halt töne der
andere macht bilder und ich machte baute
aber aber im grunde das technische
schreiben ist ist der kleinste teil
und wenn ich sie richtig verstehe
besteht dass darin dass sich folgen kann
und meiner fantasie dass die ihren lauf
nimmt das ich nicht mache sondern er
finde genau wann genau und dann ist es
schon auch so ich denke wie bei der
reise sei am offensichtlichsten wenn man
sieht wie picasso einen eine linie macht
das ist einfach eine bewegung und das
ist es beim schreiben im grunde auch die
bewegung ist also aber es ist im grunde
auch dieses die form herstellen
und was ist wenn jetzt mal eine figuren
in richtung einschlägt die ihnen nicht
passt
das dürfte eigentlich nicht passieren
das heißt sie korrigieren nicht
beschreiben das sei eigentlich von
anfang an ein es gibt das problem ist
eher wenn eine figur nichts mehr macht
also ich habe schon mal einen roman
aufgegeben weil ich einmal gemerkt die
machen nichts mehr
es geht nicht weiter weil ich eben das
wäre als würde die linie an wo abbrechen
von von markus werner gibt es diese
schöne geschichte dass er beim schreiben
manchmal mitten im satz abgebrochen hat
und dann zwei jahre nicht mehr
geschrieben hat und dann hat er sich
wieder hingesetzt hat er weiter
geschrieben
also es gibt es gibt diese momente wo
einfach etwas abbricht und in seinem
fall konnte es dann wieder anderen
auffangen aber oft ist es dann auch
verloren sie haben eine eigene technik
bei hemingway 600 wörter pro tag so
alles regelt damit sie dann wieder
wissen wo einsteigen dann am nächsten
tag hat nur eine faustregel also hast
ich glaube die die was dahinter steckt
aber nicht zu viel schreiben das ist
glaube ich die idee nicht nicht dass man
jetzt diese dieses tages pensum erfüllt
ich schreibe auch oft weniger oder oder
gar nicht aber ich zwinge mich
aufzuhören nach einer bestimmten menge
text und warum nicht zu viel
das einfach langsam und kurzen test
genau dass es dass es diese konzentriert
hat behält man kann natürlich
theoretisch kann man ihn mit meiner
stimme geschwindigkeit ich kann das
zehnfingersystem kann ich theoretisch
50.000 zeichen schreiben boden lag
aber es wäre natürlich die konzentration
lässt nach ihre werke sind auch so
wirklich so diese in sich
abgeschlossenen welten und sie selbst
die nicht an schriftsteller der sich
jetzt irgendwie regelmäßig zu
gesellschaftspolitischen debatten zu
wort meldet anders aus keine ahnung
frisch stören man hat heute vielleicht
bärfuss lüscher und sie sagen ja als
schriftsteller habe ich keine besondere
stellung ich habe nicht mehr an und
politik aus irgendeiner anderen bürger
da würde ich sagen sie haben noch eine
bestimmte distanz zu den dingen die
andere nicht haben die immer drin
stecken oder eine bestimmte freiheit ist
das nicht auch eine verpflichtung dann
sich zu wort zu melden wenn es um
bestimmte themen sind schwierige fragen
ich mal als als staatsbürger würde ich
sagen hat jeder von uns dieser
verpflichtung oder sollte sich
mindestens marschieren oder
interessieren oder informieren abstimmen
gehen ich meine es mir ganz wichtig
meinen kindern auch zu sagen man geht
abstimmen das ist das ist wichtig aber
die politischen fragen unserer zeit sind
ja häufig sachfragen inzwischen das geht
nicht mehr wie nach dem krieg vielleicht
weg gefunden um neuorientierung der
gesellschaft sondern es geht darum
saf abschaffen oder sollen die
atomkraftwerke haben sollen wir
kampfflugzeuge kaufen was ich schon
glaubt dass das meine bücher politisch
in einem viel tieferen sinn sind eben
wir haben jetzt die ganze zeit über
dieses bild fiktion realität thema
gesprochen dass er ein sehr politisches
thema heute wo wir mit nur noch mit so
vielen bildern leben wie noch nie müssen
wir uns schon fragen was tun diese
bilder mit uns auch die bilder die wir
uns von den selbst machen facebook zum
beispiel was macht das mit uns das sind
fragen über die man nachdenken wenn man
vielleicht meine bücher liest und das
finde ich ist sehr politisch aber eben
nicht tagespolitisch das nehme ich gerne
als schlusswort vielen herzlichen dank
herr stark für dieses gespräch
nächste woche lautet barbara bleisch die
grenzen zwischen traum und wirklichkeit
zwischen wahnsinn und weisheit aus und
fragt was können wir lernen von
psychisch kranken menschen
und jetzt gleich steht eine andere frage
im zentrum nämlich die frage wer gewinnt
monika schärer leitet die kritiker runde
zum schweizer filmpreis bleiben sie also
dran und einen schönen sonntag
[Musik]